[Applause]
i grew up in kuwait in the early 90s
where i was raised by screens
the main windows to reality for me were
television and the internet
not because of their accuracy but
because they were storytelling machines
these machines told stories that
contradict one another but all somehow
seem true
the arab region nukaway to be one of the
leading voices in media specifically for
comedy shows and theater
the rest of the world knew kuwait to be
a small country that was located between
saudi arabia
iraq and iran during the gulf war both
stories are true
these screens that i derived my sense of
reality from told me different and
sometimes contradicting stories about
who i am and where i come from
and that was the only way i understood
anything around me by placing it into
different sets of stories
when social media came around it changed
the way screens worked for me
it wasn't only a window for observations
anymore but an interactive one
one i could use to identify everything
around me in even more varied and
multiple ways
and to know myself better and actually
participate in the storytelling process
it started with these drawings mostly
cross-hatched on photographs that i took
with my iphone
with time i started to animate them onto
videos that told stories from different
perspectives in a mockumentary series
titled
birdwatch it consists of scripted
interviews by imagine minority voices
discussing a general issue or one of
common interests
the title of the series is meant to
ponder the idea what if birds were
watching back
what would they think of our obsession
with speed and oil
would they think we were dumb for
standing under the rain the second
episode for example is an interview with
a little girl
that tries to explain her definition of
health where she says she wants to be
like her father
be strong smoke and tell children not to
and also like her grandmother
cook good food be loved by everyone and
have diabetes
she also introduces us to the stomach
animal it's the head of an animal that's
connected to our stomachs
and its objective is to continue eating
even after we're full
you see kuwait has one of the highest
rates of childhood obesity
presenting it in an amusing story while
pointing out that children are
themselves a minor voice
is a great way to really put the
statistic into perspective another
episode is an interview with a horse
breeder
who talks about the rules of making sure
your well-bred horse is taken care of
she the horse must not be seen by others
must only mate with the same grade
must not be ridden by other men and must
be veiled
making a story about a parameter of
oppression towards women funny
especially when it has animation on live
action is a great way to walk clear
through walls of censorship
intolerance and political correctness i
tried to implement the ideas behind
these two episodes before
during my first art solo in 2014 but i
still had to put it into a story to both
be
understood and accepted by speaking in
someone else's voice
i was experimenting with detachment from
ideas i grew up thinking were axioms
we're in a strange place where our
problem is the abundance of information
where the majority of people have a
platform to be heard but representation
is still an issue
representing a certain group giving them
justice all of these stories can
naturally contradict even if they differ
slightly
we as humans are not merely the shape of
body that we occupy
or the specific description of behavior
we're a multiplicity of stories stories
that often come in repetitive patterns
that can be rewritten and reread
having been raised by screens that told
me different stories about who i am
and where i come from confused me in the
best way possible
i saw that history is not as static as
we thought
that stories can be told retold read and
reread
a change of context change of
perspective and hindsight
can assign different values to
everything and everyone around us
the way i see it that's where artists
are most important
to present meta documentations of our
history to give villains their origin
story
nothing and no one can be said to be
good or bad in isolation of the story
around it
it's much like learning a new word you
have to use it in a sentence
for it to make sense and then to
challenge its meaning
you begin to use it in an infinite
amount of stories
thank you